or dans le capitole 27 blessés sans
doute un attentat désormais des
dispositions préventives dans les gares
et dans les trains autour de columbia
sur terre atterrissage sans problème il
y a deux heures dans le nouveau-mexique
bruxelles fin du conseil européen paris
s'oppose à londres sur la contribution
britannique au budget communautaire
et puis notre dossier ce soir la grève
des internes des chefs de clinique et
des patrons de services 1 messieurs
bonsoir c'est sans doute un attentat
personnes ce soir ne peut se prononcer
avec certitude sur les causes de
l'explosion d'hier soir abords du
capitole le train paris toulouse mais
d'ores et déjà l'information judiciaire
ouverte par le parquet de limoges a
exclu en fin d'après-midi l'hypothèse
d'un accident
elle retient celle de la destruction
volontaire entre guillemets cet accident
représente donc l'attentât le plus grave
contre un train en france et il inquiète
le premier ministre a reçu d'ailleurs
cet après midi le ministre des
transports charles fiterman qui s'était
rendu sur place et celui l'intérieur
gaston defferre qui a décidé de prendre
un certain nombre de dispositions dans
les gares et dans les trains mais avant
toute chose les faits avec jérôme caby
hier soir vers 20h40 le capitole lancé à
140 kilomètres à l'heure est secoué par
une énorme déflagration qui se trouve
alors à 18km peu l'image des tôles
broyées les pompiers les services de
gendarmerie les sauveteurs bénévoles
vont retirer cinq corps pour la plupart
mutilés et 29 blessés plus ou moins
gravement d'affaires des sièges arrachés
des tôles broyées sont éparpillés sur le
ballast jusqu'à 200 mètres à la ronde
le wagon numéro 17 s'est ouvert comme
une boîte éclaté et une vaste déchirure
s'ouvre sur le côté droit
j'ai entendu une explosion times
et là la fenêtre à côté à ma droite quoi
exploser quoi des prix du lait ce qui
est curieux c'est que j'ai été baissés
de ce côté là
alors je perdais moment sang en
abondance j'avais
un peur que ce soit l'artère qui soit on
a vu cinq mois les 2 6 6 3 dans un wagon
là-haut et les blessés on une douzaine
je me suis couché
parce que j'attendais que le rail que le
train a déraillé
quand ce n'est pas arrivé je me suis
levé aussitôt je suis super super dit
dehors
et quand la ville et je suis arrivé dans
le wagon celui là et vous avez entendu
des gens qui se plaignait avis est passé
de son discours on a fait ce qu'on
pouvait gérer les gens qui saignait on a
dégagé une dame qui était son enquête
est en france et on a sorti l'espagnol
tandis que le wagon déchiqueté été
remorqué sur une voie de garage les
lieux de l'accident était très vite
déblayé pour ne pas gêner le trafic
ferroviaire très dense sur cet hymne
accident acte politique geste criminel
tout est envisagée par les enquêteurs on
parle beaucoup ici d'une altercation
entre deux hommes qui se seraient
réfugiés dans le wagon restaurant
quelques minutes avant que la bombe
n'explose
mais dans les médias les enquêteurs en
sont réduits à quelques hypothèses les
gendarmes ne néglige aucun détail chaque
pouce de terrain est systématiquement
fouillés des papiers personnels ont été
récupérés déchiré broyés par l'explosion
la question que l'on s'oppose également
la charge explosive vise est elle
vraiment le capitole et ses 300
passagers ou bien la bombe était elle
destinée à un autre objectif
ce qu'on peut constater c'est
qu'effectivement il ya un souffle très
violent des projections vers le haut du
wagon et soufflé vers la partie arrière
du du wagon est vraiment un effet de
souffle puisque l'on voit en particulier
la cabine si vous voulez qu'elle fasse
en blanc souffler donc il s'agit pas
simplement d'une valise contenant une
certaine charge d'explosifs qui a été
placé à cet endroit du wagon ou alors
pour vous aider à mieux visualiser ce
qui s'est passé nous sommes en du gare
d'austerlitz dans un wagon semblable du
capitole devaient se trouver dans une de
ces comportements pour les voyageurs
peuvent déposer leurs bagages ou lors
leurs effets personnels
la force de l'explosion a complètement
détruit
ce premier compartiment est sans doute
une partie du deuxième il y avait
certainement des personnes dans ce
compartiment
mais je n'ai pas les détails exacts
concernant l'occupation de ce
compartiment ont rogné le deuxième
compartiment touche et a certainement
été détruit en partie oui tu es le
plafond ci a été complètement détruit et
parmi les occupants de ce compartiment
parmi les victimes
l'une des soeurs de l'ancien ministre
jean pierre fourcade je rappelle que
désormais les effectifs de police seront
renforcées dans les gares et dans les
trains et que les équipes de la sncf
procéderont à un contrôle sélective des
bagages et à les opérations de détection
retour de la navette spatiale sur terre
columbia s'est posé avec donc de plus de
20 heures de retard sur le programme
initialement prévu atterrissage en
douceur à white sands dans le nouveau
mexique mais il y a deux heures mais à
quelques secondes de l'immobilisation de
l'appareil on a quand même eu chaud
georges leclercq
oui voici les derniers kilomètres de ce
vol de huit jours columbia est à 18 km
d'altitude et vol à la vitesse du son
dernier virage pour aborder la piste 17
de la base ultra secrète de white sands
au nouveau mexique
jack losma et gordon fuller tonnes sont
aux commandes ce sont eux qui pilote la
navette
maintenant elle passe en régime
automatique
la voix la descente 500 kilomètres à
l'heure altitude 300 m 2 sans sens elle
sort les roues
et très rapidement regarder toucher des
roues arrière maintenant une chose
incroyable va se produire
la navette regardez la elle ne touche
pas à l'avant elle remonte elle se
redresse mais finalement elle se pose
correctement une correction in extremis
effectué grâce aux ailerons et
colombiens roule tranquillement sur la
piste des sables blancs tandis qu à
houston au centre de contrôle c'est le
soulagement
maintenant pendant une demi heure
l'équipe de décontamination venant de
cap canaveral va s'occuper de vidanger
la navette et de chasser toutes vapeurs
toxiques pour que les astronautes
puissent sortir aisément ses astronautes
les voici en tête bien sûr le commandant
de bord jack losma qui semble peu
marquées par huit jours d'absence de
pesanteur il est vrai qu'il a vécu deux
mois en orbite terrestre
mais c'était il ya huit ans derrière lui
gordon fullerton le pilote s'il marche
difficilement c'est plutôt à cause du
vent violent qui balaye la base des
sables blancs
c'est peut-être là l'explication aussi
du redressement de tout à l'heure
briefing avec le chef de mission qui
vient de houston bonjour aux amis ça va
vous m'avez bien suivi au volant et abat
l'écusson regarder et bien sûr jacques
losma en bon pilote d'essai va inspecter
son engin un engin prêt à repartir dans
l'espace et cela dès juin prochain
fin du conseil européen de bruxelles ce
sommet qui réunissait les dix chefs
d'état ou de gouvernement de la c e
sommet accompagner si l'on peut dire
d'une manifestation de quelques dix
mille agriculteurs essentiellement
français et vous allez voir dans une
moindre mesure italiens belges allemands
et irlandais les manifestants se sont
séparé sans incident dans une atmosphère
assez bonne enfant à quelques mètres de
l'immeuble charlemagne protégé par un
service d'ordre impressionnant des
agriculteurs étaient venus réclamer un
relèvement de 16% des prix agricoles
en fait il a surtout été question des
travaux de bruxelles de la lutte contre
le chômage et de la relance de
l'investissement en europe
deux priorités retenues par tous
en revanche les français par la voix du
président mitterrand ont rejeté la
proposition de compromis qui permettait
de régler le problème de l'allègement de
la contribution britannique au budget
communautaire
betty dur on restera de toute façon
marquée par le refus français d'adopter
comme base de discussion ce compromis on
va y revenir mais la priorité des
priorités était sans nul doute d'éviter
l'échec centrée sur les problèmes
économiques et sociaux
le conseil européen a permis de dégager
certaines idées communes et en
particulier les idées françaises sur
l'espace social européen ainsi que sur
la nécessité de combattre ensemble le
chômage le plan de la politique
extérieure les points de vue sont plus
proches qu'ils ne l'ont jamais été que
sur le plan de la politique économique
qu'il y a un très très réel effort de
rapprochement est donc fait de plus en
plus nombreux sont les points communs
vous avez pu remarquer que dans la
démarche économique et surtout dans la
démarche sociale nous sommes déjà loin
des positions de luxembourg donc un
progrès net sur le plan politique
extérieure dans les termes
habituellement reconnu comme ceux de
politique extérieure étant bien entendu
que c'est un terme insuffisant car '
l'économie fait partie de la politique
extérieure et que là il reste des
différents mais n'est point commun je le
répète sont de plus en plus nombreuses
qu l'espace s'élargit
pour les européens le sommet de
versailles en juin avec les sept pays
industrialisés devraient permettre
d'établir une coopération renforcée avec
les états unis et le japon
une coopération basée sur une définition
commune des obligations qui incombent à
chacun en ce qui concerne la politique
extérieure les dix très ferme sur les
dangers que fait courir aux relations
est-ouest la situation en pologne
souhaite néanmoins poursuivre les
contacts et la coopération économique
avec la margaret thatcher n'a pas étaler
ses comptes de bonnes ménagères comme
quelques-uns le prévoyait néanmoins vous
vous en doutez bien le problème de la
contribution britannique au budget
communautaire était dans toutes les
têtes européenne et le président
mitterrand a froidement démenti tout
accord sur la proposition de compromis
donnant partiellement satisfaction aux
angles la notion d' instituer dans la
durée et une récupération par la
grande-bretagne teshome but sans que
l'on fasse intervenir à en aucun moment
l'idée qu'elle pourrait diminuer cette
restitution sur la restitution
tout ça ne l'est pas acceptable que l'on
a
aides et l'angleterre comme on soit
ramené à aider tel ou tel autre pays
comme on pourrait le mien c'est une idée
parfaitement recevable naturellement la
solidarité doit exister entre les pays
de l'europe des 10 mai que cela soit
quasi institutionnalisée ne peut pas
être accepté par la france demain début
du marathon agricole et samedi réunion
des ministres des affaires étrangères
pour parler précisément de la
contribution britannique au budget
communautaire
ce matin les participants au sommet
apprenait le décès de l'un des pères
fondateurs de l'europe communautaire
walter hallstein 80 ans qui fut le
premier président de la commission
européenne
pendant dix ans de retour à paris france
au mitan s'apprête à recevoir demain
enrico bellei werle
numéro un du parti communiste italien le
sol est là général du pc ne verra pas
georges marchais actuellement au
nicaragua en revanche il a rencontré cet
après midi lionel jospin premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste large
accord entre les deux parties sur le
refus de la logique des blocs mais aussi
sur l'idée que le développement du
socialisme dans la démocratie trouvera
son principal plus des points d'appuis
politiques au sein du mouvement ouvrier
de l'europe occidentale
enrico bioware interrogé par michel
strogoff beach notre conception leur
gauche c'est la population entre toutes
les forces toutes les composantes dogma
ouvriers de l'europe occidentale de
n'importe quelle inspiration ou rénover
les la société dans la direction du
socialisme est dans une société de ceux
d'un socialisme dans la démocratie
sur quels problèmes il y à t'il que tu
accord et convergence aujourd'hui entre
le parti communiste italien et le parti
socialiste français
difficile de la liste
il ya quelques différences qui concerne
appréciation sur la situation des
armements en europe ou bien des
différences en ce qui concerne les
jugements notamment le jugement
historique sur mines soviétiques sur les
pays socialistes il y a beaucoup de
convergences qui concerne notamment la
nécessité d'affirmer dans la vie
internationale certains principes
notamment les principes d'indépendance
nationale des peuples et de devoir
démocratique la nécessité des supers été
surmonté la logique des blocs de lutter
pour la brune réduction des armements
dans la sécurité et aussi la nécessité
de faire progresser le mouvement ouvrier
dans la voie de
un abonnement de la société les
professions médicales toujours en émoi
aujourd'hui deux grèves celle des
internes et chefs de clinique de ch une
grève entamée vendredi et semble-t-il
très suivies entre 80 et 100% dit-on de
sources administratives et syndicales et
à l'occasion le ministre la santé
jacques khalid a été chahutée ce matin à
rennes par quelques 200 internes
et puis autre action celle des grands
patrons de services depuis hier clos
crespo donneriez-vous le permis de
conduire à quelqu'un qui vient de subir
plusieurs échecs consécutifs
c'est l'un des slogans des internes et
celle du clic en grève en effet un
arrêté du mois de février sur
proposition du conseil de l'ordre
accorderez le titre de spécialiste à
tout médecin ayant échoué trois fois à
l'examen du certificat de spécialité
cette question plus la réforme des
statuts a été le point de départ d'une
grève qui concerne environ 15000 interne
et 5000 chef de clinique et qui suivit à
paris par trois capes interne et demain
par des modifications d'ordre
administratif certains médecins pourront
être qualifiés donc autorisé à soigner
votre enfant à vous opérer en ayant subi
éventuellement trois échecs à des
examens de fin de spécialité et c'est
très grave
mais supposons que cette situation de
rupture soit effective qu est ce que
vous allez faire
nous appliquerons le programme minimum
nous seront réquisitionnés par le préfet
sur autorité sur autorisation du
ministère et le programme minimum
demande l'application de nos statuts
trois heures trente par jour à l'hôpital
pour les chefs de clinique leur
enseignement à la faculté l'après-midi
ce qui fait loin des 70 heures passées
par les internats les chefs de clinique
dans les chu mise au point du conseil de
l'ordre
il n'a jamais été question de
qualification automatique mais de
mesures de rattrapage à cette grève
s'ajoutent depuis le début de la semaine
celle des patrons et de leurs adjoints
pour d'abord soutenir les internes chez
de clinique et ensuite pour une révision
globale de la fonction hospitalière
deux mouvements déclenchés pour des
motifs différents et des conséquences
commune pour les malades service minimum
dans les hôpitaux
cela veut dire pas de consultation sauf
cas précis les urgences seuls sont
assurés les patrons continuent de
recevoir leur malade mais ne font pas
payer les visites en outre ils font la
grève des formalités administratives
jack ralite lui ne fais pas l'amalgamé
entre les deux mouvements et s'en prend
aux patrons et chef de service en grève
mais en vérité ce qui a derrière tout ça
il ya la volonté d'un petit noyau qui
vivait grassement du secteur privé à
l'hôpital public se lasse et supprimer
le conseil d'état vient de me dire
d'ailleurs que c'était tout à fait
normal et ce sera supprimé alors ils
sont étriqués dans la défense de cette
chose était une chose injuste et il
chercha à agglomérer des mouvements
d'angoise créé par l'ancien régime et
pour lesquels j'apporte enfin en
conversation avec tous une réponse
nouvelle est heureuse au service des
malades
alors je crois que ces grèves elles ne
feront qu attend alors si la grève des
ânes kahn continue
qu'est ce que vous allez faire dans mon
avis la grève des internes ne continuera
pas pour le moment l'impact de cette
grève pour les usagers semblent
relativement faible mais dans quelques
jours quand il n'y aura plus de
consultations dans les hôpitaux et que
seules les urgences seront admis cela ne
représente que 10 à 15 % des admissions
la situation risque d'être beaucoup plus
difficile à l'étranger la principale
nouvelle nous est venue il ya une
demi-heure du salvador jorge apprend en
effet que les partis de droite les cinq
partis de droite ont décidé de
constituer un gouvernement d'union
nationale ils ont longtemps essayé de
demander à la démocratie chrétienne de
napoléon duarte actuellement au pouvoir
de participer à ce gouvernement
apparemment duarte semble extrêmement
réticent quant à cette solution
donc on va vers la constitution d'un
front de droite au pouvoir qui
chasserait donc la démocratie chrétienne
actuellement au pouvoir au salvador je
pense des nouvelles dans le courant de
la soirée
et puis l'hebdomadaire soviétique la
gazette l'hyper est
cet état d'un regain d'activité de ce
qu'il appelle la contre-révolution
polony la sienne que de nombreux
miliciens ont été assassinés ces
derniers temps là-bas allant même
jusqu'à avancer et le chiffre de 43
assassine on a par ailleurs appris que
lech walesa avait pu voir aujourd'hui
pour la première fois depuis la
naissance de son septième enfant
maria victoria son épouse aurait passé
avec lui toute la journée de dimanche et
une partie du lundi si jordan east
d'aujourd'hui la journée de la terre
célébrée par tous les palestiniens et
pour la circonstance la police et
l'armée israéliennes étaient en état d'
alerte sur place notre envoyé spécial
pires sert à un important dispositif
militaire avaient été mises en place
aujourd'hui tout autour de villages
arabes d'israël notamment dans ce qu'on
appelle le petit triangle de galilée
comme ici à 4 cassen charge de tout jets
de pierres riposte aux gaz lacrymogènes
c'est un spectacle devenu courant ces
jours ci les arabes israéliens et son
600000 manifestent leur solidarité avec
ceux de cisjordanie car ils sont choqués
de l'action répressive menée en
territoire occupé par goût d'amande
israël qui voit dans l'action
d'aujourd'hui la main de l'ol paie les
arabes israéliens comme les chats qu'ils
aillent un pense que ces arabes et
palestiniens ont le droit à
l'autodétermination et ont le droit à
manifester contre la politique du
gouvernement actuel là bas est comme ça
et en pensant ainsi les arabes des
alliances on pensait qu'il faut des
monstres et les ressources d'arrêter
avec ces arabes aujourd'hui pendant la
journée de la terre
ces incidents qui oppose donc le
gouvernement israélien à la communauté
arabe du pays sont fréquents
ils ont pour origine des problèmes de
cadastre des problèmes de cada ce parce
que vous savez chez les arabes depuis
toujours
la répartition des terres se fait d'une
manière traditionnelle un peu anarchique
or le gouvernement d'israël veut régler
les problèmes du domaine national un
problème donc vieux comme l'état
d'israël
simplement aujourd'hui il se compliquer
dangereusement d'une manière critique
parce qu'il ait coïncidé avec une
situation critique justement dans les
territoires occupés à gaza et en
cisjordanie où d'autres arabes
palestiniens cela reproche aussi au
gouvernement d'israël l'usurpation de
terre et cela crée une solidarité entre
ces arabes qui risque de créer aussi au
sein même de l'état d'israël une
profonde déchirure alors que le
gouvernement monsieur béguines ne fait
rien il faut le dire pour calmer la
situation
un contraire tendance à durcir sa
position chaque jour
ce matin 18 journalistes palestiniens
avaient été appréhendés par les forces
de l'ordre israéliennes
faut-il renégocier les contrats
pétroliers avec l'arabie saoudite ce
comme le laissait entendre dimanche
albin chalandon le pdg d'elf aquitaine
et bien michel jobert ministre du
commerce extérieur ne semble pas le
penser ne faut pas se contenter d'un
regard des médias sur les cours des
denrées attelly tout à l'heure sur radio
monte carlo
deux prises de position firme avec la
ville qui doivent être éclairées
l'occident consomment de moins en moins
de pétrole
un peu parce qu'ils économisent surtout
parce qu'il est en crise donc les
producteurs hors opep et autres ont du
mal à le vendre résultat baisse de la
production et surtout baisse des prix
les pays producteurs dicter leurs lois
et leurs prix quand il nous fallait
encore et toujours plus de pétrole
disons en 75
aujourd'hui ils ont perdu ce rapport de
force ils vendent moins moins cher et
quand on veut bien en acheter c'est très
grave pour certains d'entre eux je ne
parle pas des saoudiens qui ont de
l'argent davance mais des pays comme le
nigeria ou même le venezuela qui ont des
programmes de développement énorme et
d'eads est encore plus énorme et qui
risque au bout du compte les
tremblements grande tentation pour les
acheteurs est d'abord les compagnies
pétrolières de dire aujourd'hui il ya
trop de pétrole sur le marché ce sont
les vendeurs qui ont besoin de nous
profitons-en pour renégocier des
contrats moins cher et pour mieux faire
pression n'achetons plus rien à des pays
comme le nigeria justement première
réaction de l'opep
elle défend ses maillons faibles si vous
faites pression sur le nigeria dit il
vous me trouverez plus de pétrole nulle
part arabie saoudite comprise
d'abord ça fait réfléchir et puis même
si comme le dit albin chalandon le
président d'elf aquitaine
on peut à terme techniquement se passer
du pétrole saoudien
il y à un obstacle politique depuis sept
ou huit ans de peur de manquer de
pétrole
nous avons négocié d'état et à des
contrats d'achat à long terme parfois
cher avec plusieurs pays producteurs
d'état à état
en clair s'il fallait renégocier ou
dénoncer ces contrats ce ne serait plus
la signature d'une compagnie pétrolière
autrement dit un commerçant qui serait
mise en cause c'est la signature de la
france
il n'ya donc bien aujourd'hui deux
sortes de contrats pétroliers
ceux qui sont purement financiers qui
sont peut-être renégociable à notre
profit et puis ceux où le pétrole est
mêlé de politique étrangère
et ceci engage la signature de la france
et nous empêche bien sûr de profiter ces
temps-ci de l'atmosphère à la baisse
mais elle nous protège aussi dans
l'avenir des surprises à la hausse
et s'il ya bien un point d'accord
général c'est celui là pour les
surprises pétrolière on a déjà donné
le franc va mieux beaucoup mieux même il
a amorcé aujourd'hui à part une nette
reprise face à toutes les monnaies
occidentales et pourtant le dollar reste
ferme il était coté à 6 francs 24 c'est
à dire 4 centimes de moins que le record
d'hier les français et l'argent
l'hebdomadaire elle est la sofres les
ont interrogés elles s'attendent pour la
plupart à des jours moins rose mais
elles sont pour un bon tiers prête à
tout dépenser et à vivre le mieux
possible sans se soucier de ce qui se
passera après libération cette nuit de
madame benoît gardé en otage pendant 36
heures par les deux évadés du centre
pénitentiaire de liancourt
elle était épuisée mais a été plutôt
bien traité par ses ravisseurs
la mort de carl orff 86 ans le
compositeur bien sûr de carmina burana
que tout le monde ou presque connaît
considéré comme le grand représentant de
la musique allemande actuelle encore que
contester mort aussi de l'historien
d'art louis cros dès qu'ils le président
du comité international du vitrail les
oscars d'hollywood
on les connaît tous depuis l'aube
certains en cause causé une relative
surprise alors que nous voyons arriver
ici les invités le meilleur film
les chariots de feu l'oeuvre du
réalisateur britannique hugh hudson
surprise aussi que la victoire pour le
film étranger du hongrois méphisto sur
le polonais l'homme de fer de valtat en
revanche les mesures un meilleur
interprète masculin et féminin était
relativement attendu france poche le
meilleur film de l'année pour hollywood
est anglais ces chariots de feu qui
remporte aussi le prix du meilleur
scénario
ce film déjà sorti à paris quand il sort
de deux athlètes qui gagne aux jeux
olympiques
l'un pour effacer les humiliations
racistes dont il a été l'objet
l'autre pour exalter la grandeur de dieu
très le meilleur réalisateur c'est
warren beatty pour sa troisième mise en
scène il est également producteur
scénariste et interprète de wells
l'histoire du plus célèbre communiste
américain historiographe de la
révolution russe de 1917
john reade en 3h30
beatty montre la passion puis les
désillusions politiques de son héros ses
amours difficiles avec sa femme louise
et sa mort à 33 ans moscou où on enterre
au kremlin
son film a aussi remporté le prix de la
meilleure photographie avec le travail
de vittorio storaro déjà couronné pour
apocalypse now
oh
enfin prix d'interprétation pour henry
fonda et katherine hepburn dans la
maison du lac portrait intimiste et
attendri d'un vieux couple qui dans un
décor automnal s'en passer le premier
froid de l'hiver et de la mort prochaine
puis mort qui mettra fin à l'amour de
toute une vie katherine hepburn à 72 ans
en est à son quatrième oscar fonda à 76
remporte le premier dans un film prend
du parfum si j'allais vous êtes sûrement
norman ah oui sûrement
tieto bill ray bilard et oui monsieur
dans thestreet essieux oui oui oui je
voudrais vous dire monsieur car à quel
point nous sommes ravis d'être ici c'est
que celle ci m'a tellement parler de
vous et de votre charmante femme et de
votre merveilleuse maison sur le lac
ça nous a fait très plaisir qu'elle nous
a dit si franchement je suis surpris que
le chemin
oui bien et la normale et c'est la seule
chose importante nous sommes vos parents
jeune homme non mes parents ne sont plus
de ce monde
alors vous avez une bonne excuse quoi on
ne donne pas le droit de parler à nos
invités c'est ça ils ont peur que je
devienne embarrassant vous êtes à deux
monstres sacrés deux oscars donc fonda
et hepburn
voilà la météo maintenant avec vous ou
alain gillot-pétré suis parti promener
un peu partout il fait bien bien froid
en ce moment un oui oui c'est l'hiver
quasiment et demain ce sera l'hiver
parce que nous allons avoir de nouveau
des dégelées dans l'intérieur d'un matin
et puis tenez à 16 heures aujourd'hui je
dis bien à 16 heures il faisait 2 degrés
à grenoble et limoges 3 clermont ferrand
et nancy 4 à saint-etienne sac à
strasbourg 8 à paris 15 à nice et à
ajaccio quel temps pour demain regardez
moi cette carte ce n'est pas croyable il
faut le voir pour le croire
au sud du pays en gros au sud d'une
ligne qui ré de la rochelle à genève
mauvais temps beaucoup de nuages avec de
la neige sur les pyrénées de la nes au
massif central de la neige sur les alpes
du jeu rage encore de la pluie des plus
intermittente en plein et tout cela dans
une atmosphère très fraîche au nord de
cette ligne genève la rochelle ben c'est
pas c'est pas plus jolie il ya beaucoup
de nuages avec
la neige sur les ardennes sur les vosges
sur le jura sur le morvan sur le nord du
massif central quelques giboulées encore
dans l'est cela il fait froid avec des
vents de nord est assez fort tout de
même il y aura davantage d'éclaircies
sur cette grande moitié nord du pays ça
s'améliorera progressivement m'enfin
c'est pas chaud tout ça les températures
pour demain par la météo nationale
prévue par lettre simple pour demain
après midi va vous voyez de 8 à 9 degrés
en moyenne sur tous le deux tiers du
pays au nord sur le dernier tiers ce
pénible le mans 13 degrés près de la
méditerranée et à biarritz alors on
passe vite n'est ce pas demain mercredi
31 mars trois minutes de saillans plus
lever 7h33 coucher 20h18 l on fêtera les
benjamins quand même ouais c'était avec
l'autre qui nous prendra le tout dernier
journal à 23h15 il développera les les
titres que je vous rappel cinq morts
dans le capitole et 27 blessés sans
doute un attentat pour l'instant des
dispositions préventives dans les gares
et dans les trains
le retour de columbia sur terre un
atterrissage sans douleur sans en
douceur la fin du conseil européen à
bruxelles et puis la toute dernière
nouvelle step & roll
au salvador la constitution d'un front
commun des cinq partis de droite et sans
doute d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale pour le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain à 20 heures
bonsoir